Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to "Inch By Inch".
In this game, you are a scientist who unfortunately are shrinking in height.
Every. Single. Second.
Can you find the antidote before its too late and you are too short?
A new day at the lab! Let's get started.
What I need now is Ignatium!
Luckily there is some on my desk: Let's pick it up!
Time for some science! Lets put this Ignatius into the Destillarator
Okay...This machine needs two ingredients. So let's get some water and put it into the Destillator too!
Okay, and this will make explodium. I don't like the sound of explodium but okay.
**Tap sounds that sound more like piss than tap sounds**
Alright, I have water! It somehow created a beaker out of it too so that's awfully convenient for me
*Weird Huh sound* All I need to do now is to turn the Destillator on
Wait for a moment. ooookay Voi *Bleh sound*
Explodium which tipped over *Ugh* something tells me I shouldn't be this careless with explodium
"Next step is to put this new ingredient into our Bio reactor"
"The Bioreactor only takes a single ingredient but also requires a code to be programmed."
*Mark trying to say "Okay"*
"I wrote the code down and put it in one of the drawers. I just can't remember which one."
Alright.
Well, easy enough for me.
"Entering the wrong code could yield unexpected results. I'd lose this Exposium and would have to start over."
Okay, well that would just be god damned terrible.
Ah! Oooh! "Ah, there it is! This is the formula I need to the correct code for the Bioreactor!"
"7283." Okay
"Perfect! It worked! Now let's wait for a moment..."
"Explodium + [7283] = Xanolium!"...And what do I do with this?
Put it in the microwave. ...That doesn't seem like a good idea to do with anything in a lab!
Why would a lab even have a microwave?!
"All I need to do now is" blah blah blah, alright.
"The microwave is a lot easier to use than the other machines, but also takes the longest to finish..."
Alright. Okay.
When am I going to start shrinking?!
Eh?! "Sheesh, this takes ages!"
Also, this game you start out at the wonderful height of 5 foot 10, which is exactly what my height is
And we're going to go down from there. So, uh
I'm not short yet! I'm gonna be short.
"Finally! Just what I need right now!"
Hot coffee?
"A nice cup of..."
Something tells me this ain't coffee!
One, it looks too poopy to be coffee, and number three...
I don't know how Explodium turned into coffee.
"Now the real work can begin."
Oh! That was a tu...Ah.
Ah.
"I kind of feel funny..."
Ah, kind of feel that shortness coming along!
"Maybe I should stop using our lab equipment to make coffee?"
Nooo!
Oh, there I am on the left! A good ol' 5 foot 10.
"What's this?! I'm shrinking!"
"Okay, okay, no panic!" No panic, no panic here! "All I need are three components for the antidote!"
"The formula and ingredients have to be around here, somewhere!"
Alright. I got Ignatium!
Should I put that in the Distillerator?
What about...What about Xanolium?
Okay! Activate?
"While I'm waiting I should keep looking for the other ingredients", okay.
I got Exodium! I don't know what to do with Exodium.
"If I get too small I may need stairs and bridges to get this equipment." Okay.
Alright. What do I do with Exodium?!
"I should build some from random objects while I still can."
Alright. Di-Alright, I'll put this here, I suppose...
I'm 5 foot 6! A WHOPPING 5 foot 6!
"I must have gotten the formula wrong! I have to revert this and try again."
How do I revert...? What?
"I must put this useless ingredient in the Chemical Reverter, right below the bookshelf!"
Ah, I'm getting shorter!
It's my worst nightmare! What am I gonna...Where's the-- I don't see a god damned bookshelf!
Oh, it, uh, here we go.
No? No, no!
The bookshelf? Ohh, oh!
Okay, alright, well that's gonna go wibbidi wabbidi wubbidi woo.
Alright, we're going to put this here, we're going to create a little bridge there, to there.
"Xanolium + Lynxium = Explodium."
Well, I-- *stutters* Well, okay, alright!
Wait, no! That's--But I did water--
It's Xanolium plus Lynxium.
Alright. Okay. Can I have my...Uh...Xanolium!
Alright. We're gonna do this.
Why do I need to make Explodium again?! I already have Explo--
Oh. Exodium.
Ah.
Well, where's the god damned code?
Well, this is going to be a problem!
Um, here?
And...there, I guess.
Ah, shit, I'm in some kind of trouble here!
I'm 4 foot 4! I'm the height I always said I was!
Oh, hey, whoa, let's see
"Ignatium + Microwave = Key 3."
Key 3?!
What does key 3 mean?! How many keys are there?!
Oh, boy, okay, "Explodium + [2743] = Key 1."
Key 1?! K-key one?!
Okay, wait, hang on. Oh, God, I'm getting so short!
Okay, what was it? Hippity hoppity hippity! Hippity...ha!
Okay, "2743," okay 2743...
Alright, that's gonna make key 1
And then, uh...Ignatium + microwave! I have ignatium.
Don't I have ignatium? Do I have...Ah, I have Ignatium!
Ignatium!
Oh, the microwave too high!
Ah! There we go, okay.
Ignatium on the way. What else is there?
There's gotta be more right? Oh boy, "Damn it! I'm getting too short to reach the table!"
No, I'm not! I'm a perfectly...capable...handy height.
Ah, there's gotta be like, uh, a clipboard up here or something.
Something I shoulda looked at when I was taller!
Oh, no! Oh, hurry up!
Ah. Oh, tiddy sprinkles. I am...
I am all kinds of...I"M 2 FOOT 11?!
How did I get that short?! Wait! No!
I, uh, seem to be a perfectly height.
Not 2 foot 11.
I don't have enough for the other keys, I, okay
Key 1, "the first key ingredient! It goes into the antidote processor, next to the computer!"
Ah! It's so high!
Ah, hup, there we go! Okay, I got one!
I need more! Uh, can I -- I can step on a boot.
Alright, that's my -- This is my table, uh.
Um, ah...
Ah, oh, um
Ah, ugh!
I don't -- I have no idea what the other keys would be, I'm just kind of stuck in a perpetual loop of 2 foot 4-ness!
What do I do with the Explodium?!
Exodium?! What do I do with Exodium?
What...what do I do with Exodium, please, do something about Exodium.
I, oh -- No!
Come back, please, please, oh, I'm so tiny!
Maybe I could...Oh!
Put you in the chemical reverter? No?
No? Oh God! Alright, how about...
Distillerator...plus...water?
Ah, it's the only thing I can think of.
Pick it up, pick it up. I can't pick that up?
"Some of these objects are getting way too big and heavy for me!"
Well, tough it up, 1 foot 8 me!
"I can only carry increasingly small items..."
Ah? Wha? But that doesn't make any sense!
I gotta go, I gotta go get, I should, I should think ahead and get the larger ones first.
Okay, sure. Ah!
A key, "my second key ingredient! Quickly, add it to the ingredierator!"
Okay, alright, I got 2 of 3, I think.
Oh, I am so boned.
"Only one more"? Oh! There's only one--Oh!
Dah, this is not gonna work, the Exodium is not gonna work with water.
There's no way that's gonna be the key ingredient!
I'm 1 foot 4 and shrinking, HELP!
HELP, I'M NOT SHORT! I'M PERFECTLY AVERAGE HEIGHT!
Ah, please, give it, give. I don't know what you're gonna make, but please make something good for me.
Ah! Tylium?!
Tyler?!
Ha, ah please! I ju-- Oh, I can't reach it!
Um, is, I don't think this is it. Oh, everything is so big!
Aahh, I'm a big boy!
Okay, oh. Oh! Tylium! Plus 2866!
Ah, please! I, I'm not tall enough to be able to get up there.
Ha, ugh! Ha, agh!
Put it in there, okay 2866.
I gotta get something to get up a little higher.
I need that boot! Oh, I'm 1 foot 1.
Oh, I'm what I've always said I -- Aagh, it's SO heavy!
Oh my god! Okay, maybe it's...
I'll do it like this. Yeah, okay, okay, please, please.
Oh no! Okay, I'll just jump on the -- Oh shit!
Okay, I'll just jump on the boot
Ah, get me up -- Oh, no!
Oh no! Come on, come on, come on, please
Uh, that's good enough! Yes, okay.
What was it? Uh, "2866."
2-8-6-6. Enter. Okay.
While you're doing that, I'm gonna go try to figure out a better bridge for uh, uh, uh, THAT, over there.
Come here, come here, I can't pick it up!
I got a book! Books are my only friend!
Knowledge is power.
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm so tiny! Ah, oh no!
Oh no! Please!
Please! Please, and get the boot on the thing.
Boot on you.
And then, uh, that'll be enough to get, yes.
Okay. For now. Not for long!
I, I can't jump on that, can I?
Oh! Yes, just barely! Okay.
You're gonna give me this. Come on!
Ah, come on!
I'm 9 inches tall! I mean, if you round up to 10, I'm 10 inches tall!
And that's good, that is good.
Uh, can I, um, maybe I can use like these to, gah--
I'm just going to throw them down, just cause it's all I got.
Okay. Yes! Give, give, give! This is the last one!
The antidote! "That's it! That's the last ingredient." Okay!
Ah, I fell! Noo! *whap sound effect*
Give, oh my god! Okay, here I go!
*singing a little* If I'da known about that, good thing I lucked out on the water.~
Okay, ah, ah, no!
Oh no, no!
If I open that drawer, maybe, maybe that'll get me up
Come on, no!
Let's go, let's go, come on, ah
Open the drawer, open, get in, open the drawer.
Ahhh! I'M IN THE BOOT!
Noooo!
*wail of despair*
I'm in. The boo -- I'm. in. the boo-- I'm in the boo.
I'm...stuck in the boo--
I'm in the boot.
I didn't know you could be in the boot!
Nooo! This is a pathetic end!
I have to wait all the way for 7 inches?!
Oh, this is bullshit!
*distorted* Oh, this is bullshit!
Dah, pissed off! I just have to be mad and smoll inside this...Muh.
I just...so stupid!
This is stupid.
If I'da built better, if I could -- I dropped the book!
I dropped the notepad, and like the thing I could have made like a ramp, ahhh!
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad, I could have beat this! I could have beat this, I could have beat this no problem!
If I hadn't been an ass...hole.
"This is getting ridiculous!"
Yeah, I know! I'm in a freaking boot!
"I don't have a way to climb these tables, there's no way I can finish the antidote at this size!"
I KNOW!
*stutters* I'm try--Whoa! Whoat! Wha! Whoa!
I got outta the boot! But no!
It's too--Jump on the drawer!
Ah, well, tiddy sprinkle me!
Oh, you, you really? Oh, you give me a sliver of hope and then you throw it down my throat?!
Ahh! Come on! I'm not small!
I'm perfectly...normal...
Average height, ah it's gonna end the game on me.
Ah, I'm a strong boy but this is really heavy!
Ahhh, tits! Why did--
Why couldn't I get out of the boot before?!
Damn a duck, god--Ah
Oh oh oh oh, I, uh...
"I think I'm too small to use any of the equipment!"
Yeah! Oh, oh...
*irritated noise*
Goddammit.
Alright, let's try this, AGAIN.
"Draconium + Microwave = Ingredient 3."
Okay. What have we got?
Draconium. Microwave. Pop, pop that bad boy in, let's do this.
Okay, we got Strawberry Jam. What the *unintelligible* strawberry jam? Why is it straw...Strawberry jam?
Why do I need strawberry jam?
Alright, whatever, I got all of the ingredients. They're there.
Okay, let's look for this goddamned clipboard, there's probably gonna be two clipboards again -- There's one of 'em!
Okay, this is, uh..."Strawberry jam + Lycium…" equals Iced Tea? What the?
What the? Strawberry jam...plus...Lynxium...Lynxium? Equals iced tea.
For some reason, that's important.
Oh, that's already there, okay let's make the boot--
I think I should be able to get from the boot to that,
but just in case, let me put like a book underneath it.
Book. Then boot.
And that'll be enough to get me up there. Probably.
Let me get this here, just in case. No.
AH! Ah, that's not what I wanted!
Um, uh, uh, goddammit, okay
I've got this! Is this a key ingredient?
I don't know! Hooby dooby doo!
"Iced tea + [6719]"
Okay. Iced tea...6-7-1-9
I am getting shorty short!
*remixed* Why am I so shorty short?
Okay, I need to find, uh, one more clipboard,
there's gotta be another clipboard here somewhere!
Whoa! "Ignitium + [7036]"
Okay! I've got, that, that's important.
I'm gonna put that on the ground,
just in case I see that later.
Got it! ...One of 'em.
Okay, first key ingredient, put that in the bad boy. That's going in that bad boy
And then this is...going...where did I throw that? Okay.
Ignatium equals Darkium.
I don't know what the fuck Darkium does.
I don't have anything...Darkium?
Dar...darkium plus water equals key 2!
Okay! Uh, as soon as I make Ignatum
I'm gonna make Darkium
Okay, this is ready.
Put this in here. I'm gonna make some Darkium!
Put this...in...there
Get the ahuh...
*stress scream*
Give me--Take the--Give, give, ahh, no, no
Ahh, here, you
And then, what's the code? 7036
Okay, 7-0-3- I'm really losing height quickly!
There, and then boot on you!
Nooo!
Boot. On. You.
Stay!
Go! I'm 3 foot 4!
I need water. Uh, uh, water. Give me water.
*pouring sound* How long does it possibly take to get water?!
Okay, gimme gimme gimme give me you, give me you!
Oh, it's so heavy!
Uh, bloop, okay water
Come on!
Come on!!
COME ON!
Okay, Darkium, got it.
Okay, Darkium plus water equals key 2, I think.
Yes...Darkium, go!
*singing* Come on baby, come on baby, I'm about to hit 2 feet!
*still singing* I hope it doesn't pause me at the height I am!
*singing losing track* If it does then that's kind of bullshit because I am a perfectly AVERAGE *voice crack* 5 foot 10 and I'm happy with that!
*still singing* If there's an antidote that can make me taller, that would be really great! Hurry the hell up!
ANY MINUTE NOW! Would be really cool.
*stops singing* Okay.
Okay, cool, give, give me that!
Okay! "That's it! That's the last key ingredient I need! Here I goo!"
Okay, got it in there, I need to go up
"I did it! I've stopped shr--" What?
"Uhm..."
"How do I get big, again..?"
Uh...
Oh! *laughs*
Oh, okay! Alright!
I guess that's just it. *giggles*
This has been "Inch By Inch."
It's a really clever idea!
I feel like they could expand this in a big way if they put more effort, uh, into the, the levels,
and like the intricacies of it!
It's, it's kind of an interesting concept to fight against the clock by shrinking
and the challenges that it presents are really interesting,
so thank you everybody so much for watching!
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below,
if you have any other suggestions for games that you would like me to play, NO! I'm not short. If you think I'm not short
Write "I'm not short" down in the comments below.
If you think I'm a perfectly average height, then, yeah, say that was well.
Also, we're going to Australia and Amsterdam!
Check out tour.markiplier.com to see if we're coming to you real soon.
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
Let me know what you think down in the comments below!
And as always, I will see you, in the next video! Bye-bye!
*Music outro*